Let's have 1 molar of-- let
me pick a strong acid.
Let's say it's hydrochloric
acid.
HCl.
And we know, of course, that
since it's a strong acid it
disassociates completely.
So HCl in an aqueous solution--
or a solution of
water-- disassociates completely
into hydrogen ions
in an aqueous solution, which
is really hydronium.
I've said that multiple times.
Plus your chlorine anion
in an aqueous solution.
So if you actually have a molar
of this, as soon as you
put it in the water, you really
have 1 molar of this.
So your hydrogen concentration
is really 1 molar.
And of course we know, what's
the pH of that?
Well, the pH is just the minus
log base 10 of your hydrogen
concentration, which is 1.
Which is the minus log of 0.
So minus 0, which
is equal to 0.
So your pH is going
to be equal to 0.
And let's say for use in the
later part of this, let's say
I have a liter of this.
Right.
This just tells me how many
moles per liter, and now I
just told you that
I have 1 liter.
So you know that you
have 1 mole.
Let me make a little
chart here.
I'll make a little box here.
And let's make this
access right here.
This is going to be my pH.
And right when I take that first
measurement-- let's say
this is 0 here, this is 7,
and this is 14 up here.
When I take that first
measurement, my solution of
hydrogen chloride, or
hydrochloric acid, has a pH 0.
Now, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to titrate this
aqueous solution of acid.
And titrate just means drop
something else into it in
controlled increments
to see what happens.
And what I'm doing here
is going to be
an acid-base titration.
I have an acid here, and what
I'm actually going to titrate
it with, or the reagent that
I'm going to add to it--
The reagent is essentially a
reactant that, when you view
it this way, that you're
adding to the solution.
So it's the titrant.
So in this case, my solution
already has
hydrochloric acid in it.
The pH is already 0.
But what I'm going to
do is I'm going to
add a strong base.
Let's say sodium hydroxide.
That's my favorite
strong base.
And let's say I have a solution
that I have prepared
ahead of time.
Let's say it's a 1
molar solution.
But I'm not going to add all
of it at the same time.
I'm going to add it
in increments of
a tenth of a liter.
So this is 1 liter
that I've added.
And then this would
be 2 liters.
And so this would be
500 milliliters.
500 mL.
This is 1 liter.
This is 1.5 liters.
This 2 liters.
And so on this axis, I'm going
to slowly add more and more of
this hydroxide.
So what's going to happen?
As I slowly add hydroxide, it's
going to increase the pH.
Why is it going to
increase the pH?
Because this OH.
Remember, hydroxide
is a strong base.
So the NaOH disassociates
completely
in an aqueous solution.
To OH minus plus
sodium cation.
Right?
Now if I'm adding this to this
stuff here, what do you
think's going to happen?
Well this stuff right here,
these OHs are just going to
sop up your hydrogens.
So for the most part--
obviously, everything is
probabalistic.
And whenever we're dealing with
chemistry, there's always
some molecules that won't
completely react, and there
will always be some
concentration of anything.
And that's why you actually
can never get to a 0
concentration of hydrogen, no
matter how much base you add.
Because there will always be
some hydrogen molecules that
are just hiding just perfectly,
or they're in
perfect equilibrium so
they don't react.
But most of them will react.
But as I add more H, these
are going to disappear.
So my hydrogen concentration
is going to go down.
The pH is a negative log of
that, so your pH will go up.
Your pH will go up slowly--
well, it will look slowly,
because it's a log chart,
so maybe it's doing
something like this.
Your pH concentration is going
to look something like-- as
you add more and more.
But you might say, oh that's
such a slow movement.
Why isn't it occurring faster.
But you have to think
about something.
This right here, if this is a pH
of 1, this means-- so, at a
pH of 0, this means
your hydrogen
concentration is 1 molar.
At a pH of 1, this means your
hydrogen concentration is at
10 to the minus 1.
Which is 0.1 molar.
So even though on a log chart
it looks like you've made a
very small movement, you've
actually gone
by a factor of 10.
In terms of your reduction of
your hydrogen concentration.
You started off with 1 molar
of your hydrogen.
By the time you've added roughly
900 milliliters of
your solution, you probably
would have gotten
rid of most of it.
And obviously the denomenator's
changing,
because I'm actually
adding volume here.
Right?
Because I'm actually adding
some volume here.
So you would have to add them.
But you get the I
general idea.
That these actual molecules of
hydroxide are going to react
with these things.
They're going to essentially
turn into water and disappear
into the solution.
So these are going to
disappear with those
disappearing, for
the most part.
Which leads in an overall
reduction concentration of
your hydrogen ions, which
will lead to an
increase in your pH.
Until some point where you have
pretty much sopped up as
many of these things
as you can.
There will always be a few of
them, but you've sopped up as
many of them as you can.
And so any incremental hydroxide
you add will
actually go to build the
hydroxide concentration.
Where the hydroxide
concentration is going to be
greater than your hydrogen
concentration.
But even better than that,
there's going to be some point
where you've added just enough
of this that you have an equal
amount of this and this.
You have an equal amount of
hydroxide and hydrogen.
Right?
What happens, first of all, when
there's an equal amount
of hydroxide and hydrogen?
Well, then you're neutral.
Right?
If your hydroxide concentration
is equal to your
hydrogen concentration,
you're neutral.
This is just like water.
You're at a pH of 7.
So there's some point where your
hydroxide concentration
is equal to your hydrogen
concentration, and your pH is
going to be 7.
And then above that,
you're just adding
more and more hydroxide.
The hydroxide concentration is
overwhelming your hydrogen
concentration.
And so you're going to get
really, really basic.
And since this is a strong base,
you're eventually going
to get to a pH of 14.
Because you're essentially going
to have-- well, you're
not going to have 1 molar.
Let me erase that point.
You're going to have
half a molar of OHs
at the end of this.
So your graph is going to look
something like this.
Now, I mean, you're still
going to have hydrogen
concentration, but it's going
to go really small.
It's going to get really,
really small.
Now.
What's interesting about what
just happened here?
At this point right here, your
OH is equal to your hydrogen.
And the way I think about it is
the great majority of your
moles of hydrogen were sopped
up at that point.
So in order to stop up 1 mole of
hydrogen, you essentially,
for the most part-- and there's
always things that
don't get completely sopped up--
but you'll essentially
have to add 1 mole
of OH to sop up
your 1 mole of hydrogen.
Remember, this is 1 molar and
you had 1 liter of it.
So you had 1 mole of
hydrogen to sop up.
So you need 1 mole of OH to sop
up, and how do you get 1
mole of OH?
Well, we said the concentration
of the solution
was 1 molar.
So once you put a liter in
there-- because that's 1 mole
per liter-- once you put a liter
in there, you would have
put 1 mole of hydroxide
cations in there
to sop up the hydrogen.
So this is the equivalence
point.
Where have essentially, you have
an equal amount and very
low concentrations of both
hydroxide and hydrogen.
You've essentially sopped up all
of the hydrogen, but you
also have sopped up all
of the hydroxide that
you've added so far.
After this point, any hydroxide
you add will
essentially contribute to
increasing the pH even more.
Or it'll kind of overwhelm your
hydrogen concentration.
Now what's interesting
about this?
In this example, I told you, oh,
I have hydrochloric acid
and I gave you its concentration
ahead of time.
But let's say I didn't
tell you that.
Let's say it was some mystery
substance, and you just
measured the mystery
substance's pH.
At this point, you said
OK, it's pH is 0.
And you titrated it with
this sodium hydroxide.
And you said, well, gee, when
I added 1 mole-- because you
figured out at a liter of the
solution-- of hydroxide ions.
At that point, I've essentially
eliminated all of
the hydrogen ions that were
in my original solution.
So I must have had 1 mole
of whatever acid
this was over here.
So this would have told you that
my initial concentration
was 1 mole of H plus.
And since we know it's easy to
see how much volume you have,
you see I have a liter.
So you say my original
concentration of
this acid is 1 molar.
And you could also know that
what you're dealing with is a
strong acid.
And I encourage you to watch the
next to do I do the same
thing with a weak acid.
But because it's a strong acid
and a strong base reacting
with each other, when you have
the same number moles of both,
you get exactly to a pH of 7.
They completely neutralize each
other, and you have a
completely neutral solution.
If you had a strong base with a
weak acid, the strong base--
once you have the same amount as
the weak acid, it would've
neutralized it.
But you would have also
had some of the
conjugate weak base left.
So you would have actually
ended up with a basic pH.
And I'm going to do that
in the next video.
But if you see that the
equivalence point occurs at a
pH of 7, you'd know that you
were titrating-- what you were
dealing with was
a strong acid.
Because it was completely
neutralized, not more than
neutralized, by the
strong base.
And if you want to eye-ball
where is equivalence point,
you look for the steepest
point in the graph.
Because that's the point where
you're going from having a
majority of hydrogen versus
hydroxide, to having a
majority of hydroxide
versus hydrogen.
So it creates this inflection
in the graph, and you just
would have to look
at this chart.
And say, I added a liter
of this solution.
The concentration of this
solution is 1 mole per liter.
It's 1 molar.
It has a molarity of 1.
So I must have added
1 mole of hydroxide
to get to this point.
So I must have neutralized
1 mole hydrogen.
So there must have been 1 mole
of hydrogen to begin with.
And since I had 1 liter of
solution, I had 1 mole
hydrogen and 1 liter
of solution.
So my original molarity was 1.
Anyway, I don't want to
confuse you too much.
In the next video, I'm going to
try to do the same thing,
but I'm going to do it
with a weak acid.